[Music]
I'll let you do you oh yeah I'll do man
I'm not doing man oh man still work on
that accent here I got everyone hiding
hey here is jag nation Greg I'll be here
with Megan away to Yamada scene from my
brother's channel or as I call him my
brother anyway guys I know right
shame mega lane you can follow her on
social media
she has social media just like most
normal people do she's actress dancer
writer martial artist yet she has a
black belt thank you we're gonna fight
each other later to see who will win
most likely it's gonna be her for sure
actually yeah yeah you've heard of a man
named yeah that's the noise that's the
spider-man but yesterday I don't realize
I'm wearing a Wonder Woman sure but you
got upset so many Marvel fans today ah
take that I'm sorry
I'm watching the spider-man on Thursday
night at a really late night show so
that a review probably won't be up till
Friday civil war vlogs some people
theorize this might be the opening of
the cell which is great I just love the
more ruin for me the best getting right
get my hope so yeah
a film by Peter Parker please don't be
talking to no one
just making a little video to chat yeah
you can't show it yeah I think are you
happy
not carrying it back till hey should I
gonna be bathroom before it's a bathroom
on whoa nope awesome
very exciting did you first tell me baby
playboy know exactly why Andrew what I'm
doing something about Captain America's
going where's the case let's go I don't
understand it is it for me
happy happy way it's insane insane look
at this thing look Captain America
actually she'll knock through it and
throws amazing things about mr. James
Lipton actual - you are the instrument
right Thank You detective
okay yes in walls here
ladies a little video diary sorry to do
it he was filming everything on the way
to chip hey you know we should actually
we should make it an alibi video for
your hand any days right
oh and a visitor hey anyone what do you
want something Skippy I hope haha hey my
gosh I want to tell you what a crumble
job
your nephew did this weekend at the
start internship retreat everyone was
impressed
it's a frigging merge because you're not
increase over see happiest is hoping to
get bumped up to an asset management was
for head of security and for that exist
a driving private conversation I don't
like taking the adapter for this
fortunate auction
no seriously positional order bus right
yeah yeah happy to get on you want me to
leave like a brat Peters case that'll
turn tendency should yes we're just
lucky
do me a favor go happy spend of your
point then in this don't stress enough
don't do anything stupid
we've seen a story exam all right don't
do anything I would do and definitely
just a idea with you there's a little
gray area near member you agree what do
you get me Nona give you this seven four
I'm gonna puke
you didn't take it I can't thank you oh
wow I love that yeah I love that I was
so much fun I'm kind of poking like on
the DVD or bluray but they have a
special like 90-minute version where
it's all spider-man's log of the whole
experience
yes that was so cool he's a youtuber
peter parker's relatable he's doing what
they use does I feel like II just think
I mean soon movie obviously it's like II
got to your partner now yeah my decide
for today's kids are today good thing
yeah as much as I like Tobey Maguire and
I even like Andrew Garfield I feel like
this might be the perfect isn't he seems
reminiscent from just this footage
alonein from the trailers yes I grew up
on the 90s cartoon and I read a couple
of comics growing up I really feel like
this captures the personality then I
really need Peter Parker tubulin and
super nerdy
I love how like he doesn't he have a
motormouth problem yeah yeah yeah he's
seeing everything that's on his mind
nothing look why I was very like
brooding kind of like yeah solemn yeah
but yeah and then Andrew Garfield even
made it more that yeah if there was a
quiet shy and Andrew Garfield was like
rough inside of the train tracks yeah
yeah this has the right personality I
love it I love everything he's doing
here the whole vlog
rendition of it if I was so delightful
and yeah I wonder if the beginning it
should be I would be very surprised if
it's not the beginning we can hope it's
not because I want to begin in the movie
think I haven't seen ya that's true but
with spider-man especially they tend to
release a lot of clips for their movies
and movie marketing in general they tend
to do that maybe it would be cool this
is some special little viral video that
they released for us let me do a little
bit yeah yeah yeah a special internet
video that would be really cool at the
same time I think I can appreciate that
as a smooth transition because he was
coming the last time we saw him was in
Captain America Civil War so that is a
great way to tie it all in and like it's
a good flow transition into it all and
it was it's fun seeing how he like
discovers the suit and all that because
you know get that moment in Captain
America Civil War where he finds his
suit he just shows up living updated one
yeah yeah and I like his relationship he
has a Jon Favreau your happy happy just
seems to not like him at all I don't
know why he doesn't like it yeah but I
can't wait it you just find them
annoying or something yeah I mean
happenings having for a reason right
because it's an ironic
this is grumpy all the time I hope we
get a lot more of him and happy because
that seems like the fun dynamic because
Tom Hollands spider-man seems completely
oblivious to how he's coming across the
how that how annoying that can be to
other people like in child like a child
yeah he's a child I love it Anna
you know Tom Pollock and really do all
those flips and stuff no I didn't know
that when he was petitioning himself to
be to be spider-man he would put videos
online of him just doing flips huh
tonight a real gymnast and all these
things what more do you want from this
waiting for her yeah actors who can
actually be believable around saving
people it's sad when when they when it's
obvious it's not them but I think like
that flip that one back look he
does--like every day with me to be to
get out you do superheroes and I just
York City
so there's humor thank you
Thank You detective coming doesn't look
very CGI does it look like wires your
life is away in his body
yeah the way how to smooth it is it like
even prep to do the flip yeah it does it
do ya so shallowly yes yeah can you flip
yeah you can flip at a gymnastics
background be quick yeah do you have
flipping videos I guess throw in here
right now for the for the audience in my
pocket really good section to me we'll
throw it in the other movie yeah
should you a fight scene Megan yeah I'm
going to sudden okay yeah when they had
the scene where they're talking in the
car I think that is a good transition
I'm really interested in seeing Peter
Parker's life I wonder if he is going to
vlog this whole time I really think they
should release like after the movie is
out on blu-ray so I'm like really long
vlog at Tom Hall and put together well
that'd be brilliant
cuz that's so relatable so relatable I
mean what's the matter
hit that vlogs in like snapchat I'm
hiding so Laurie all that guys now this
is perfect
the marketing on this movie is brilliant
man they know the you all right guys
spider-man homecoming keep a lookout for
my review coming up this Friday I'm so
excited to see this movie I will be
wearing a spider-man shirt not a Wonder
Woman shirt to the theater I'll just
send you this out you know what I love
about comic book nerds on the Internet's
especially not even like people in front
of the camera the commentators if you
like effect to get one thing wrong or
you do something slightly like wearing a
Wonder Woman shirt and then people start
hating on you as if they're like the
tiger is an EXO w should die do you
think like a worse things to you
oh and I'm like you're a comic book nerd
you're in Concord what makes you feel
what am I really gonna believe you're
this really tough guy who like bench
presses at the gym and martial arts
trains then goes home and just read the
[ __ ] on it Tommy is
I'm going to threaten you on the
internet like as if you're a real threat
to me subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell
follow Megan Lai on social media
immediately linked in the description
box and check out our patreon for fun
goodies on their dances good punch think
you weightless do ya yours
some kind of machine aren't you Megan